you've heard me mention libs of tick
tock many times on this show it is one
of the greatest accounts on the internet
in large part because it's so simple
libs of tick tock just reposts public
videos from libs on tiktok
they just repost it to the other social
networks notably twitter
they expose radical sexual and racial
lessons in classrooms they expose the
realities of those lessons in the lives
of confused young people they don't
offer commentary they don't constitute
investigative journalism
they just present the libs
in their own words and actions
and the liberal press can't stand it
so the washington post is trying to
intimidate libs of tick tock into
silence by doxing this private citizen
who runs the anonymous account
the washington post sent a reporter i
don't even want to call her a reporter
the washington post sent an operative
taylor lorenz to harass the anonymous
woman's friends and family
to literally knock on doors
and then to reveal personally
identifying information about her
the washington post initially tried to
deny the doxing once this all came to
light they got a lot of backlash and the
post said no no that that didn't really
happen the post defended this this
operative taylor lorenz and the post
insisted
we did not publish or link to any
details about the woman behind libs of
tick tock's personal life that was a
complete lie like so much that is
printed in the washington post it was
just a total dishonest fabrication the
paper did reveal the woman's name
occupation religion for some reason and
even linked hyperlinked to her personal
physical address
a link that the paper later removed
after public backlash
and then they denied that they did it in
the first place
the doxing looks bad enough for the
washington post and for taylor lorenz
but it looks even worse it looks
perfectly worse because just a couple
weeks ago
lorenz was crying crocodile tears on
camera about the horrors of being doxxed
as a journalist
you feel like any little piece of
information
that gets out on you will be used by the
worst people on the internet to destroy
your life
and it's
so isolating
and terrifying
it's horrifying
i'm so sorry
it's overwhelming it's really hard
i think she needs to work on the
performance a little bit not not exactly
meryl streep
judy dench she is not you notice there
are no tears she's just doing a kind of
caricature a clown show of what it would
look like if she were crying but she's
not really crying she's she's not really
upset because she's the perpetrator of
these kinds of things
lorenz and the washington post are a
laughingstock
hypocrisy the likes of which you can
we haven't seen in a long time and and
really all you can do is laugh the whole
thing totally backfired but the libs
still want to shut down libs of tiktok
so now some of the largest blue check
accounts on the internet are posting a
fake tweet
that supposedly shows libs of tick tock
endorsing pedophilia
this is obviously a preposterous hoax
anyone with two brain cells to rub
together can see right through it which
unfortunately leaves a lot of people who
get their news from the liberal accounts
liable to believe the hoax doesn't make
any sense at all why would this account
libs of tick tock endorse the very thing
that they spend so much time railing
against
what the whole fair affair does reveal
is everything you need to know about the
difference between the left and the
right today
when the left attacks the right they
censor us
threaten us
and make up things that we never said
when the right attacks the left we play
their own words back to them verbatim
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from ranger smith
who says great news the cdc never had
this authority to start with as a
non-compliant non-mass wearer from day
one i celebrate this but i agree we
never should have allowed it to start in
the first place i agree of course it
shouldn't have started it's a problem
but the one place you're wrong is you
say that the cdc never had this
authority in the first place
obviously they do have this authority
they claimed the authority they
exercised the authority the people in
elected government and all the other
authorities acknowledged that authority
so they they do have it we can bury our
heads in the sand and pretend that our
government is run just like we were told
it's run on in school house rock with a
bill up on capitol hill but that's not
the way that our constitution with a
lowercase c actually works in practice
the way that our rules are made our laws
are made the way our government is run
is by all these alphabet agencies that
are largely unaccountable to
us the people and if we want to if we
want to stop it if we want to restore
some semblance of the traditional
american way of life we've got to
acknowledge that and we've got to take
that power back and and deal with that
reality we got to fix things when you
want to fix your car where do you go
rockauto.com
right now go to rockauto.com enter
knowles in their how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you the
value of your car or pickup truck or
minivan or whatever you drive has almost
certainly appreciated significantly this
past year will take care of your
automotive investment keep more of your
money by buying the auto parts that you
need to maintain and repair your vehicle
at rockauto.com rocoto.com not only has
the auto parts that you need but they
will give you a selection of trusted
name brands to choose from you pick the
brakes that match how you use your
vehicle whether that's for towing racing
or just commuting to work which in my
case would be the same thing as racing
you can get exactly what you need super
duper easy to navigate website so simple
even i can do it same price for pros and
do-it-yourselfers these guys have been
with us since the very beginning of this
show we love them at rockauto.com head
on over there right now for your auto
parts and then write knowles k-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
the libs
are furious
that we're hearing what they have to say
they're furious about it
and so they're acting in this vindictive
horrible hypocritical way
now
some people are saying two wrongs don't
make a right
to michael we shouldn't be
investigating taylor lorenz now we too
wrongs taylor lorenz is a public figure
first of all she writes her articles and
her hit pieces with her name right out
there she goes on television she
presents herself with her real name
so at least when we're talking about the
distinction between public and private
that gal is fair game totally unlike the
woman who's behind libs of tiktok the
other distinction of course is that the
woman behind lives of tick tock is
actually doing a journalistic service by
exposing the reality of what's going on
in america's classrooms taylor lorenz is
nothing but a democrat operative who's
working for a liberal billionaire named
jeff bezos who runs the washington post
the washington post which
simply is the propaganda mouthpiece for
the liberal establishment we've got to
get a lot tougher okay we've got to get
a lot we've got to go after
the the liberal press and we've got to
stop treating them as though they're
this wonderful sacred check on power
that democracy dies in darkness no
they're nothing other than a bullhorn
for the most powerful interests in the
world they deserve absolutely no respect
they deserve nothing but our scorn and
derision and we've got to make that
clear
an article in the washington post should
carry absolutely no weight whatsoever
some conservatives get this some
republicans get this we used to play
nice and we used to try not to rock the
boat too much i think that's over i
think we're it's becoming very clear
where the political battle lines are you
see this nowhere clearer than you do in
florida
ron desantis in florida passes a
parental rights and education bill
the libs call it don't say gay our
friend vivek ramaswamy calls it wait
till eight
so you can't you can't trans the kids
until they enter fourth grade
nine years old that's the line before
that before that you're not allowed to
talk to them
about weird creepy sex stuff in the
classroom
and disney which is a big corporation in
florida
operates disney world and is a kid's
company as a family company they're
furious and they want to have a bunch of
weird gay transgender whatever stuff in
in all of their movies now
and they want to fight the will of the
people of florida and the ability of the
people of florida to have some say in
their kids education so ron desantis
could try to make nice and be
conciliatory and say hey listen guys
let's all come together and disney i
understand you're a powerful interest
here so we're going to try to placate
you but please may okay let's compromise
uh first grade that'll be the limit you
can't trans the kids in first grade but
second grade maybe no that's not what
desantis is doing desantis is actually
going on the offense and he came out
just yesterday and he said that not only
are they going to stand up to disney not
only are they going to stand up for
parental rights but actually maybe
disney's special tax protections that
they've had for 60 years maybe those are
going to have to go away if disney keeps
trying to undermine the ability of
florida parents to govern the way that
their kids are educated
what they've been called upon to do but
i am announcing today that we are
expanding the call of what they are
going to be considering this week and so
yes they will be considering the
congressional map but they also will be
considering termination of all special
districts that were enacted in florida
prior to 1968 and that includes the
reedy creek improvement district
so
this sounds
sort of like normal bureaucratic
political talk well we're redistricting
and maybe we're going to change the
protections of certain districts the
reedy creek district that ron desantis
is talking about is is
disney world
not just disney world the park but
that's that is
within the purview of the disney
corporation they get all sorts of
special treatment there and the santa
says okay look guys
we didn't want this fight
we just wanted to protect six-year-olds
from being exposed to transgender
weirdness in the classroom
disney brought this fight disney said
we're going to throw around our
gazillion dollar corporation and all of
our might
to undermine the rights of parents to
educate their kids so okay you want that
well since you you brought the fight to
us we're going to fight back and we're
going to take away your tax protections
and what are you going to do by the way
are they going to shutter up disney
world i don't think they are and if they
are fine by me see you later we're going
to open up daily wire world there
i can't wait please disney bring it on i
can't wait that way we'll get we'll get
the daily wire amusement park and i can
be a huggable character
everything is going gay
to quote blake masters who's a
republican running for senate in arizona
not everything has to be gay i'm not i'm
not saying we got to be mean to people
or put stick our nose in all of their
private business but
how come everything has to be lg but
forget about everything it's gay now
everything's got to be transgender in it
why why is that hollywood is announcing
that there are going to be remakes of
movies
remakes of fight club and my best
friend's wedding
but here's the thing about the remakes
they're going to be really gay
that's it that's the pitch meeting they
go into the hollywood executives the
hollywood executive says all right we've
we've only been churning out terrible
movies over the past 10 15 years so we
need some good new original ideas they
say i've got an original idea what if we
do those other movies that were already
done but we make them super gay
wow get that man a million dollars what
a genius idea so there's gonna there are
going to be these remakes that are right
now in the works
it's nothing other than
culture vultures coming in taking
products that did work from the past and
instead of coming up with new original
ideas
just trying to give a kind of woke
politically correct spin on them we've
seen this constantly in recent years
reboots of the superhero movies to make
them more woke reboots of go
ghostbusters right hey what if we take
ghostbusters but make it all chicks
won't that so we'll just we'll do a
worse version of the movie because it's
already been done so you if you're gonna
remake it it's not gonna be as good and
then we're just gonna make it all women
hey hey let's do ocean's eleven but it's
all women how wasn't that a great no
there's nothing interesting about that
at all
that's the solution to a problem that no
one had
so they're now they're trying to make
that and it's not because it's going to
be particularly entertaining it's not
because we even need a remake of fight
club or my best friend's wedding
it's just to advance a liberal agenda
you will
sometimes hear
conservatives when they're talking about
the bill in florida though now it's a
law the parental rights and education
law they'll say look
this is not about lgbtq
this is this is about any sexual
education i don't i don't think
kindergarteners should say gay in the
classroom but i don't think they should
say straight in the classroom either
this is a line and i understand
conservatives are using it because
they're trying to make clear that this
is a bill about education and parents
rights is not
about targeting
lgbt
fair enough but at a deeper level
this actually is about lgbt
it is when we
when we talk about what can be said and
not said in the classroom
probably the strongest argument that the
libs have against the florida law
is that if you're in a math class
and you're doing word problems
you could have scenarios where you say
all right um
johnny's parents
johnny's parents tommy and sally go to
the store and so how many people go to
the store right they say well tommy
johnny and sally okay that's three
people or the word problem could be
tommy and his johnny and his pair i
forget what the kid's name is johnny and
his parents go to the store johnny tommy
and steve well hold on wait those are
his parents or two guys or his parents
are a guy and a girl and and
let's say you're you're reading a story
book it's kindergarten right you're not
having very advanced lessons here and
you read a storybook and you say all
right
little baby bear is sitting by the fire
with his family mama bear and papa bear
and his sibling bears
well you could read that story that's
totally fine there's nothing nothing
wrong with that i is it teaching
some aspect of sexual morality i guess
it is if you mention the family you're
teaching some aspect of sexual morality
i don't think anyone would have a
problem with that law with reading that
book in florida
but if the book said johnny is sitting
with his gay bear daddies
johnny daddy bear and billy daddy bear
and his transgender bear sister
skylar and then i think we probably
would have a problem with that because
it is advancing a more radical novel
sexual agenda
and i think we need to be honest about
that that they are they are different
they are different things and drew made
this point on backstage just the other
day and i thought it was a really good
point people have a right to standards
we have a right to that it is when you
talk about mommy and daddy having kids
that is different than talking about
daddy and daddy's boyfriend having kids
they're they're just different things
and one is normative and one is out of
the ordinary and eccentric and more
novel
those they're actually different and
they
must be treated differently in culture
because cultures always have standards
and norms and taboos and
all sorts of things and we have a right
to our norms
people like traditional standards okay
there's nothing wrong with that
there's no it's not to say that we need
to be mean to people and
exclusionary and
bigoted or whatever but
it's okay to say that in the normal
operation of things
boys like girls and girls like boys
and men and women are different and
complementary and there's nothing wrong
with and that's the way things are
supposed to be there's nothing wrong
even with saying that that's just
acknowledging facts of nature and
standards in reality people like their
standards the other day is there a
completely different aspect of this
topic
when the the court came in and struck
down the mask mandate
on a lot of flights mid-flight the
captain will come over the speaker and
say hey
we're getting there's no more mask
mandate uh so you can take your masks
off if you want and people were cheering
everyone was excited
there was one airline steward who was
walking down the aisle with a trash bag
saying throw out your masks he wasn't
just saying it he was singing it
[Applause]
love it we've been talking a lot about
singing on airplanes over the past few
days because there was this kind of
eccentric evangelical band that at 30
000 feet started playing extremely
modern worship music and some people had
a problem with that well i don't think
anyone has a problem with that steward
singing throw away your masks and
everyone's happy and everyone's throwing
them away why
because it's weird for everyone to be
walking around with masks even beyond
the public health questions and the
medical advantages of the masks which
were obviously so overstated from almost
the very beginning at the very beginning
fauci admitted that the masks don't do
very much but then later on he changed
his tune and we all had to pretend
but that i don't even think that's what
the the mask issue is about
i think it's that
we don't want to walk around like
banditos we don't want to walk around
like we're wearing these scientistic
secular burqas all the time we want to
see each other's faces we want to
breathe the fresh air we want to see
smiles we want to go back to normal
normal that's an important word and
normal involves
standards and normal involves
expectations that we have of society
in society we have a right to see each
other's faces
you you don't have a right in society to
walk around with a mask on all the time
like you're a burglar or a or a bandit
about to rob a railway car
you don't have a right to that
we have the right to the expectation
that when you come into a public place
we're going to see your face
we're going to know who you are
we have that right the standards there
was
basically there were three views of the
masks for for almost all of the
lockdowns the first one was the libview
which is that you always need to wear a
mask all the time with seven masks on
when you're alone in the car
then there was the centrist view
the individualist view you can wear a
mask if you want to or don't wear a mask
if you want to it's your right to
completely decide whenever you want to
wear a mask i i have always been of the
conservative view which is that
generally speaking with few exceptions
you should not wear a mask in public
it's weird it makes everyone feel
awkward it puts everyone on edge it's
not normal it arrests the social
development of children and it's just
ugly and i want to see your face you got
a beautiful face i want to see it
give me my standards the white house is
furious about this the white house was
was asked jen saki spokesman for the
white house was asked what to make of
the court decision
what what do we make of the
changing science and now the changing
guidelines on the masks
there the white house wants to appeal it
but jen saki's simple answer was
i'm not a doctor
you said about this mass ruling out of a
federal court in florida that it's a
disappointing decision and you say you
continue to recommend that people wear
masks
why is it that we can sit here in the
white house briefing room with no masks
but people
can't sit in an airplane cabin with no
masks well peter i'm not a doctor you're
not a doctor that i'm aware of if you're
a doctor i wasn't aware of that today
until today
okay not a doctor just making sure i
don't know um
nor does he play one on tv there you go
most days um but these determinations
remember the masking guidance is there
are is green yellow and red we are
currently in a green zone in washington
dc so they're not recommending it some
people can still wear a mask if they
want to many people do or wear them in
meetings or wear them at certain times
where you're going to be around or
sitting close to people or maybe you
have an immunocompromised parent or or
friend and so people make that decision
and there's this is based on health
considerations and data that the cdc
looks at about transmissibility as as
we've seen increasing cases on on
airplanes
jensaki is not a doctor katanji jackson
is not a biologist i'm not a weatherman
but i know which way the wind is blowing
okay
and we can know these things you don't
need to be a genius to to know
that it is disordered to
to muzzle yourself
in perpetuity in public it's disordered
and now it's over because thankfully
one judge on a federal court said enough
is enough instead of one faceless
nameless unaccountable bureaucrat
telling us that we all have to muzzle
ourselves you have one judge who's
slightly more accountable i guess coming
in and saying no enough is enough
good thing
when you want to protect not just
your norms in society today but your
future your retirement you got to check
out alto ira right now go to altoira.com
michael when you do anything in life
there's one way to do it and then
there's
usually the smarter way to do it if you
think about it just a little bit you
might already be investing in
cryptocurrency did you know that you can
trade bitcoin ethereum and over 80 other
cryptocurrencies in a tax advantaged ira
with an alto crypto ira you can trade
all those great
coins that you like to trade
in a way that will allow you to avoid or
defer taxes does that sound nice it
sounds nice to me altos crypto ira is
the easy way to get crypto into an ira
trade all you want without that tax
headache create a new account just a few
minutes you can invest as little as 10
bucks with no setup charges
more than 80 coins available
if you want some sushi swap with your
bitcoin no problem alto has you covered
plus there are multiple ways to fund
your account with a cash contribution
transfer cash from an existing rra roll
over a 401 k
alto makes it so easy open an alto
crypto ira account with as little as 10
bucks at altoira dot com slash michael
a l t o i r a dot com slash michael
start investing in cryptocurrency today
go to
slash
autoira.com
who
locked us down who upended our society
who made us wear that dumb
filthy cloth for two years
you know who folks you know decta deck
defouchy we have a series exposing this
man you want to talk about actual
investigation actual exposition of a
major public figure well that would be
the fouchy unmasked series all three
episodes are available to stream right
now
i if i do say so myself i think it's a
really important three-part docu-series
especially because this guy wants to
come back he wants to exercise that
power again the biden administration is
fighting tooth and nail to keep this
mask mandate to keep the national
emergency order to keep all of the coved
regime in place take a take a listen
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr
fauci began to set national policy that
affected the way that 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you where a mask keeps
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
dr anthony fountchen don't you think
it's time that you step down and let
someone else who has a more effective
message
actually no
[Music]
bouchy unmasked is available exclusively
at the daily wire so if you're not a
member yet head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe to join today
people have been loving the show so i
really appreciate that one of the best
performing pieces of content on our
website right now or ever so do not miss
it we'll be right back with a lot more
paul krugman who is the radical
left-wing economist writes for the new
york times
krugman
insists that the masks are not about
freedom he says a prediction about
masking soon will be seeing many
incidents in which those who choose to
protect themselves with kn 95s etc face
harassment even violence because this
was never about freedom
i don't think that people who wear the
dumb masks are going to face harassment
or violence but i do think they'll
probably be mocked
i do think that they will probably be
looked on as neurotic and kind of weird
because with few exceptions unless you
have very very specific medical
conditions you really shouldn't be
wearing these it's completely
ridiculous
and i think that's a good thing
because he makes one good point here
which is this is not about freedom
exactly
it's about
how we're all going to live together if
i lived in saudi arabia right now it
would be totally normal for women to
cover their faces all the time
i don't live in saudi arabia i live in
america
but unfortunately it has become normal
for all of us to cover our faces all of
the time
that's not just a question of freedom or
tyranny or slavery or any of these big
abstractions it's just customs it's just
how we live
people in certain cultures wear a
certain kind of hat people wear a
certain kind of dress people behave in
certain ways some cultures shake hands
some cultures bow it's just customs it's
just mores it's just standards
and so the battle about the masks and
about
actually about whether we're allowed to
shake hands or not or about how we learn
or about how we live or how we shop
that that battle is is a lot more
complicated than just the freedom or
material it's it's about how are we
going to live what are our customs going
to be and what kovid did so effectively
is upend totally blew up all of our
customs because
the the people who run the show the
people who run our government and our
corporations and the powerful
institutions in our country don't like a
lot of our customs and they want to
upend our traditional way of life
so krugman's right with this ruling that
people are thrilled about you're hearing
the cheers on airplanes and offices and
everywhere
people are so happy about it it's about
going back to our regular way of life
and all the angry neurotic people like
paul krugman and all of the libs who who
just wanted to sanitize the entire
culture and keep the filthy dirty hoy
polloi away from them they're going to
be really upset about it and we're going
to laugh at them and it's good for us to
laugh at them we should laugh at them
they are
worthy of mockery they are ridiculous
they are worthy of derision when they
push things like this
now speaking of violence and freedom
there is a criminal
in los angeles
who is very very happy today
this is
a criminal with a long rap sheet with
gang affiliations this is a murderer
this guy
is going to have face
far lower charges
than he otherwise would have because
there is a george soros-backed
very liberal district attorney in los
angeles who's letting criminals off the
hook and he was just recorded on a phone
call with his attorneys this not the d.a
but the criminal and he says i'm gonna
have to clean up some of this language
because i'm gonna get canceled if i use
some of these words
he says i'm gonna get that n-word's name
on my face that's a champ right there
effin gascon
that's gang member luis angel hernandez
uh talking about the d.a george gascon
this s-h-i-t looking real good he says
in a phone call now we got a new da in
la so they're going to drop a gang of uh
like my gun enhancement my gang
enhancement my gang enhancement is ten
years fool for being a gang member do i
sound convincingly like a gang member i
don't know now i've gotta i'll have to
work on my performance just like taylor
lorenz at wapo needs to work on her
performance whining about doxing i'll
have to work on mine as being a gang
banger
my gang enhancement is ten euros fool
and then the gun in the commission of a
crime that's the n word right there bro
he's making historic changes for all of
us fool
i'm just grateful fool like i got good
news off that s-h-i-t they're like you
coming home blood
they already told me my lawyer already
told me you're coming home
this is being reported by fox news it
almost reads like it's out of a cartoon
i have actually have trouble believing
that this guy is saying it except that
the d.a really is letting these people
off the hook
and and the the gang-banging psychopaths
are they might be total lunatics but
they know where their bread is buttered
they know where they owe their debts and
this guy owes a great debt of gratitude
to george gascon because as a result of
george gascon's
policies as district attorney you're
going to get a lot more
crazy
murderous
gangster psychos on the streets that's
the effect so more people are going to
get hurt more people are going to get
killed more innocent people more
innocent taxpayers citizens of los
angeles are going to wind up the victims
of violence
because this
district attorney would rather
prioritize
luis angel hernandez
and and would rather prioritize his
interests over the interests of the
people who want to remain
safe
there was a recall attempt against this
d.a
it didn't work it's very hard to recall
people
but i it's hard to see
how this plays very well and
so why is he doing it why is this
district attorney letting these breaking
bad level caricatures of psychos off the
hook
he's doing it one part ideologically
because the left believes that the only
reason that bad people do bad things is
because society has somehow failed them
and so actually it's our fault it's
never the criminal's fault it's always
the victim's fault it's victim blaming
in its purest form that's the
ideological reason why this is happening
but then the raw political reason why
this is happening is because chaos
breeds opportunity for the libs this is
why they always want to upend not just
our standards and mores and traditions
but law and order itself civil society
itself this is why the left encouraged
the blm riots this is why the left this
is why kamala harris the sitting vice
president raised money to bail out the
most violent people in the george floyd
riots
is because when there's violence on the
streets when when buildings are burning
when the law is not being enforced when
the cops are being defunded when whole
police departments are being abolished
that gives the left much more
opportunity to tinker with society a
society that they they believe that they
can remake through their own unfettered
reason that's why this is happening it's
not an accident it's not just that the
d.a is incompetent it's that he's a
radical and he's getting exactly what he
wants
now the only problem for him is that
people don't like this we don't like it
when there are gang-banging psychos
running around on the streets i know
this is shocking news we don't like that
we don't like it when millions of
illegal aliens are flooding into the
country we don't like it when gas is
going through the roof we don't like it
when inflation hits 40-year highs so
then the question becomes
how are these people going to hold on to
power
look at joe biden joe biden is not only
in terms of the actual effects of his
policies the worst president
possibly ever it's not even just that
it's his fault it's that he happens to
be
president
at a time when his political party is so
far to the left and he just blows with
the wind he just does whatever they want
and he also has a brain made of pudding
so he's not not able to really control
very much he's not particularly
competent either and so the consequence
of that is that he's just the worst
president probably that we've ever had
certainly that we've ever had in recent
memory
his his approval rating is in the
doldrums and yet he says
he's going to run for president again
according to the hill which is a
left-leaning publication
joe biden has has said
to to at least two people and to barack
obama
that he will run again and biden
reportedly believes that he is the only
democrat candidate
that will be able to defeat donald trump
if donald trump runs for president again
his cognitive decline must be really
really bad if he believes one that he
can be re-elected with an approval
rating in the 30s and 2 that he's going
to beat donald trump
or it just means that he's living in a
total bubble where all he's hearing is
the good news from nbc and the
washington post and all of the other
propagandists for the the establishment
just like in north korea you've got
you've got
the
crazy dictator who surrounds himself
with propagandists well it's it's not
all that different here if if
joe biden is only ever listening to and
reading the washington post the new york
times nbc abc cbs and cnn then he is
getting a slant on the news a
pro-administration slant on the news
that is not all that much different than
what kim jong-un is getting in north
korea
so that might be it
or the third option is they think that
they can rig the election
again they think that they can push for
widespread mail-in ballots like they did
in some cases unconstitutionally and
illegally in 2020 they think that they
can extend election day to election
month they think that they can
tilt all of the scales in their favor
but the bookies right now
las vegas doesn't believe that joe biden
can beat donald trump or another
candidate by the way so one way that
people make predictions it's so early on
that any prediction about who's going to
win in 2024 is basically worthless
but you can look at public opinion polls
that's one way to do it or you can look
at the money where are people putting
their money in terms of
bets on who wins and right now
according to gambling.com's resident
betting expert joe short
joe biden's not looking great
the presidential election odds put joe
biden as the third most likely candidate
to win the presidency
above him way above him at number one is
donald trump and the number two
ron desantis
so right now you've got trump at the top
desantis joe biden followed by kamala
harris harris jeff bezos nikki haley and
then further down the line you get other
people uh
buddha judge ted cruz other people as
well
i
i definitely recommend caution when
you're looking at when you're making
your political picks based on
predictions two years out from more than
two years out from a presidential
election don't forget
in 2016
you had the early favorite uh i think
scott walker was probably the earliest
favorite followed by
who
marco rubio
ben carson
was chris was chris christie ever in
there he might have been in there i
these things go through cycles in 2012
or bobby jindal maybe he's going to be
the one or you know
early on these things don't really
matter but the reason these numbers
matter is not because of who the
republican is going to be it's because
of how
unpopular joe biden is not just against
some generic republican but but against
actual people who are getting a lot
of press
what do the democrats say about this
well donna brazile who's former head of
the dnc who goes on and
spouts the party line on all the
mainstream media outlets donna brazile
says they're actually the republicans
are running on fumes and all of the wind
is in the democrat sales
all we have to do is wait over the next
37 days as 11 12 states hold their
primaries you have big primaries in ohio
and
north carolina pennsylvania where the
pre the former president has already
tipped the scales in support of one
candidate over another the republicans
are essentially running on fumes they're
running on the energy of 2020 which is
the big lie democrats are running on an
economy that's roaring back that is
fighting inflation that is helping the
ukrainians democrats will run on what
they've delivered republicans are going
to run on the fumes of 2020.
i don't have very much to say about this
woman's analysis other than that it is
completely worthless
it's it's it's not even that she's
making some radical point i'm going to
debunk it what she's saying is just
totally divorced from reality it's not
true that republicans are running on
election fraud in 2020 they're just not
they're running on the economy and
they're running on inflation it's not
true that democrats are doing anything
to solve inflation or the economic
problems or that people even think that
they are just none of this she's just
making things up and it
it exposes just like the libs of tick
tock story expo it exposes to you how
worthless the
establishment corporate press really is
i was walking through an airport the
other day which is the only time that i
ever see the liberal press on tv in real
time
i was listening to some analyst in a
very s in a suit with his tie giving his
expert analysis on how joe biden's doing
a great job and i just thought this is
so worthless these guys are such shills
there's such hacks
that
i don't even think you can call it
reporting or proper journalism
it's it's nothing other than propaganda
and
the the only way that it works i think
as people are tuning out and cutting
their cable and not paying attention to
them the only way it works is if they
intimidate people silence people censor
people and rig the game
social fads are moving really really
fast
you know
we call it the current thing that's one
way that in the internet meme culture
people refer to the the social issue du
jour
one week it's one week it's ukraine and
everyone's totally focused on the war in
ukraine but before that it's i don't
know the masks and before that it's
me too and before that it's blm and it
just changes by the week
and this is going on for a while now as
i was recently reminded do you remember
coney 2012
coney 2012 was about this
warlord gangster type in africa named
joseph coney and he had some army and he
did all sorts of terrible things
but for a few weeks
in 2011 and 2012 everyone was obsessed
with this and they all changed their
facebook profile picture and they all
said we're gonna go get kony 2012. we're
gonna get him we're and this is so
important in the whole world but they
didn't do anything it was just
slacktivism
it was just changing your profile
picture
it was it's largely what people are
doing now with ukraine they're not doing
anything to really help ukraine but
they're changing their profile picture
and that's the most important they don't
know anything about it they couldn't
pick ukraine out on a map they don't
know anything but they're
really gung-ho about it and before that
it was the masks and before that it was
the vaccines and before that was me too
and before well
these things
change they come in cycles and the
cycles are increasing in their frequency
clearest evidence of this i meant to get
to it more than a week ago but i don't
want to miss out on it
louis ck
won the grammy for best comedy album
louis ck who i think is a funny comedian
he's not my favorite comedian but he's
very funny he
got me two'd some years ago because he
from what i can tell i think they were
consensual maybe some of them weren't
but i think they were consensual where
he would
uh
expose himself and do weird things in
front of women
i don't think he was accused of rape or
anything like that but he had some weird
sex stuff behind him and then he was me
tood and he was totally chased out of
the industry and now he's back
it shows
one i think the end of the metoo
movement i think that's totally over
when you when you now have leftist
activists forcing men into women's
locker rooms to expose themselves like
that guy will thomas on the penn swim
team when you when the official line of
the liberals now is we need to force men
to get naked in front of women who are
unwilling and undesiring of of seeing
that then obviously me too is completely
gone out the window it also shows you
that these are just movements of
convenience they don't really care about
women they don't really care about
the
koni they don't really care about
ukraine they don't care about any of
this it's just it's just a way to get
really riled up and to have a kind of
political religious ecstasy and to score
a few cheap points on your opponents and
then move on that's all that this is
really about and so that the question
then for 2022 and 2024 is what are those
going to be
the left is going to have to find some
great crusade to rile everyone up about
and pretend that this is the the
do or die
end of the world scenario
meanwhile contrary to what donna brazile
is saying here
republicans i think are going to run on
the basics
gas is too high inflation is too high
immigration is way too high boys are not
girls stop transiting the five-year-olds
really basic fundamental stuff it
doesn't get you riled up in a crusade du
jour but it's pretty important to people
speaking of women
in show business
julia roberts
julia roberts did something the other
day
that i i have to focus on because no one
is really talking about it and it's so
great it's one of the most positive
developments i've seen out of hollywood
in a long time in large part i think
because it took place outside of
hollywood
there was a piece in the new york times
there was a long interview with julia
roberts
and she stood up
for
homemakers
julia roberts is 54 years old now
and she addressed her long absence from
rom-coms we haven't seen big julia
roberts rom-coms in many many years at
this point
she said here's the thing
if i'd thought that a script was good
enough i would have done it
but i also had three kids in the last 18
years that raises the bar even more
because then it's not only is this
material good it's also the math
question the math equation of my
husband's work schedule and the kids
school schedule and summer vacation it's
not just oh i think i want to do this i
have a sense of great pride in being
home with my family and considering
myself a homemaker you go girl i love
this this is so i don't just love this
because julia roberts is exalting
traditional standards and a traditional
way of life
i love it because she is expressing her
joy
to lots of women who need to hear this
because what she's saying is objectively
true and it is a better way of life and
it's much more conducive to happiness
than what lots of women are being fed in
school and by the popular culture which
is that they need to ditch having a
family put off getting married put off
having kids possibly indefinitely and
just go work in the widget factory for
some other guy until they're too old to
have kids and then they can be really
regretful about that
julia roberts
is sending a message here and it's in
the new york times i can't believe the
new york times let this through
that is so imp
i i never want to hear again from some
feminist that look forget about having a
family forget about and look i'm not
saying everyone needs to get married and
have kids there's religious life there
are other callings as well but forget
about all that forget about all those
important significant things in life the
most important thing to do is to go work
in middle management and do spreadsheets
alone in my studio apartment in some big
city that's the most important thing i
can possibly do and nothing else matters
that's just a lie
i never want to hear it from them again
because the people who say that have
really relatively modest careers julia
roberts has one of the most spectacular
professional careers of any woman of her
age
and she kind of gave it up
she could have gone much she could have
done a whole lot more movies she could
have made tens of millions more dollars
at least and she didn't she said no
that money
that fame that celebrity that adulation
is actually not worth anywhere near
the value of
having a home having a family having
kids who love me
going on summer vacation with the kids
having making dinner
do going over homework with the kids
these are really
basic
things that we used to understand in our
traditional way of life that for all
times throughout all of history and all
places certainly in our civilization and
in many other civilizations as well we
have known or true and there is a
concerted effort by political radicals
to upend and to deny and to pervert all
of those things don't let them do it you
will be the victim
if you let them do it won't be a great
cause of liberation it won't be a way to
finally overcome the bourgeois terrible
oppression of the past you will be the
victim it will make your life worse
cling hold on to those traditional
values they are what are going to fetter
us to reality into a flourishing way of
life i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show